in this country a federal court jury is
deciding if three men convicted of
chasing down and murdering ahmad arbury
are also guilty of hate crimes greg and
travis mcmichael have already been
sentenced to life in prison without
parole in georgia william roddy bryan
was sentenced to life with the
possibility of parole after 30 years the
charges in federal court allege that the
man killed arberry because he was black
janet schamelian is in brunswick georgia
janet good morning
nate good morning to you the sequester
jury will be back here soon to resume
deliberations after closing arguments
wrapped on monday prosecutors telling
the jury the defendants did not see
arbory as a human being and they
referenced racist social media posts and
text that the men made in the years and
months before that shooting
almost two years after the pursuit and
murder of ahmad arbury the fate of the
man convicted of his murder is in the
hands of a jury again
this time facing federal hate crimes
charges their attorneys claim the attack
was not racially motivated but stem from
the belief the 25 year old was involved
in criminal activity
prosecutors told a different story
saying travis and gregory mcmichael and
william roddy bryan were driven by
racial assumptions racial resentment and
racial anger
twenty witnesses testified some claiming
they'd heard the mcmichaels make racist
statements
text messages and social media posts
with the n-word were also introduced to
establish a history of racist views
legal analyst joe tambourino so
the text messages the facebook posts are
relevant even though they've happened
over a past number of years
yes they are because what it gives the
jury is an idea as to whether or not
these three defendants have racial
animosity toward black individuals the
mcmichaels tried to enter a plea deal
before trial but the judge rejected it
after arbory's family opposed it this
has been very draining
and i'm thankful that it's almost over
aubry's mother and father were in court
for the closings all i can say is we
just want
justice 100 percent justice just for
full month
aubry's mother is hoping for a verdict
by wednesday which will mark two years
since her son's death several events are
planned here in atlanta to remember
arbory and to recognize the changes that
have been made in state law since his
death and there are
the federal charges
rather carry a maximum sentence of life
in prison if the men are convicted tony
all right we'll be following along
closely janet thank you very much